your mother
convinced me to let her join me on my
missions
they called her the wasp
she was born to it
and there's not a day that goes by that
I don't regret having said yes
it was 1987.
separatists had hijacked a Soviet
missile silo and Kursk
and launched an ICBM at the United
States
[Music]
oh
the only way to the internal mechanics
was through solid titanium
I knew I had a shrink between the
molecules to disarm the missile
but my regulator has sustained too much
damage
your mother
she didn't hesitate
turned off for regulator
and went subatomic
deactivate them
and she was gone
your mom died a hero
and I spent the next 10 years
I've learned all I could
about the quantum Realm
you're trying to figure
that all I learned
as we know nothing
it's not your fault
she made her choice
I was trying to protect you
trust your mother
I didn't mean to lose you too
this is awesome
it's awesome you know you guys are
breaking down walls you're healing
it's important
I ruined the moment didn't I yes she did
yes
I'm gonna make some tea
foreign